[Music]
who do you think is the most admired
person in the world oh i thought you're
going to say i'm in this in this room
hell no not after her well let's start
small that's definitely
not exactly right sorry i have a couple
i'm a couple years off
i think so everyone used to love her oh
they
everybody loves everybody until they
don't oh beyonce is a good guy
it's pretty up there i would say obama
but there's a lot of people who
think half half of the country so
there's a lot of people who believe
obama was a terrorist yeah that's it
oprah who doesn't like open opera no
no dude she was tied in with weinstein
she's bffs away yeah she watered her
garden during the drought you can't take
dieting advice from someone that can't
stay on her own diet that's true
oh true that's it true but i do like her
because she rescued maui from japanese
businessman
you know that story she got a hella she
i think she bought land and then said
i'm gonna just leave my farm here
and then they were gonna build a hotel
and then she was like i'm just gonna do
this
for maui did you guys hear the story
where she gave everyone a car that was
pretty nice and then they had to pay
taxes on it and they were all in debt
pissed i think the most admired person
in the world is kermit the frog
he's not a person though no he's not
he's not happens
frog okay hold on admired person it's mr
rogers
that's the reason why we have pbs by the
way kermit did a lot of misogynistic
things to miss piggy i think
yeah but miss piggy was on board he was
aggressive she was aggressive
she was borderline sexually harassing
kermit the whole time i was so annoyed
of her
it's okay for a woman to be open with
sex no she was aggressive
men can say no consent is consent we are
not i felt bad for kermit
man she was so thirsty oh yeah she she
was like
curvy you guys wouldn't even be
complaining if she was hot
and you know it and you know it who said
that piggy isn't attractive
huh who said that so you you think she's
not attractive she flipped it back on
you
no i think this biggie's hot i swear
i think she's so hot damn it she listens
all right so here i have a list of the
world's most
admired people oh i know one yeah the
colonel from kfc
a live joke oh sorry did you see his
story we'll talk about it
oh never mind yeah no no it's
interesting he looks like a chinese
grandpa so
so this survey is split between genders
there's a there's a male side and a
female side
we already know that's problematic the
male side ding ding ding tiff you got it
right
bill clinton obama obama obama's the
most admired
man in the entire admired admiral in the
entire world yeah
not only us like they surveyed the
entire world and uh
did they forget about matthew
mcconaughey did not make the list
all right top five who do you think the
top five is i can't say
alive men men men in the world admire
admired yes
brad pitt because he's always making the
top 20. wow i am
i'm not going to say anything but i am
kind of shocked by this list
bill gates number two and he was number
one for the longest i think six years in
a row since they've started doing this
survey
and just this year barack obama passed
him up on number one
okay what about musk musk is at number
nine
top five okay is it living in dead cause
yeah honestly honestly in the top five
there's only one other name i think you
guys would know
and you're not gonna guess it yeah
there's like no way you're gonna guess
this
none none no give me a chance give us a
hint
he had a cartoon at one point in time
that's not a good hit
mike mike tyson no when i say it you're
going to get it
jackie chan oh we're going to play games
we're taking it
that was good game night jackie chan
that's
my partner first off you got it off of
the cartoon
yeah it's weird yeah because a lot of
people like him he's the number one most
paid actor
yeah and i was thinking the world truly
that's him that's true he's global and
he had a cartoon and he did the jackie
chan adventure
i love that i like that shanghai nights
but shanghai noon shanghai night
yeah shane he was a shanghai kid in it
yeah they should just call the shanghai
kid it was really just a jackie chan
movie it was
not normal yeah okay so who's number
three i don't even number three xi
jinping he is the current president of
china you got to be [ __ ] kidding me
he's only winning because it's the
chinese populations
you have to say yes well check it out
number four is narendra modi
and i checked him out modi's india he's
india he's the president of india or
that the leader of india so a lot of
these people are
politicians this is a joke list well i
mean he's paid for
true yeah but then that's why i had to
think after obama
i was like okay who who's just the most
popular and why would they be admire
bill gates number okay ready for number
two number 12
vladimir putin exactly so basically the
leaders of all the biggest
highly populated on there then oh yeah
trump is on here he's that number 15
number 15. didn't he get voted in his
opinion he's number one
yes yes is angela merkel on there angela
merkel
germany oh that's a female side oh yeah
you know she's there she's she should be
number top five genderland
i saw her she's number 12 on the females
number 12.
that's crazy
top five top five beyonce michelle obama
beyonce is not
beyonce is not top five she's the number
one just kidding
michelle obama michelle obama is number
one really
because i said brad pitt angelina
jolie's number two oh
he's a huge humanitarian so i love how
like there's no
male actors on this list yes that's
exactly what i was thinking about so
does it say george clooney's wife
because nobody knows her name what's her
name what's her name
a mom is it a mom that's true they
always refer to her george clooney
she's like i'm a successful lawyer
we're so sorry george clooney's wife
we're so sweet i'm absolutely gorgeous
and brilliant and i'm a lawyer
and she's had twins she is and she like
was a u.n ambassador
she is brilliant honest she should be on
here okay kind of like angela merkel's
husband
who is he true doesn't she even haven't
done anything i don't even know she was
married i don't know
i don't know all right so uh number
three is queen elizabeth the second
is that's that's the current queen right
i don't know what they do in the second
i was like
who's the second no no yeah yeah it
wasn't the grandmother
of the number yeah wait her mom is
prince andrew her
a car queen liz or princess i have no
idea prince philip is her
phil yeah okay the guy with the big nose
right yeah he's
well they all got huge noses that's true
i mean that's hard is that true
wait which one was diana's charles
charles
okay so phillip is her man
is elizabeth that guy well philip's not
on this yeah
is the queen's husband yeah okay but how
come he's not the king because she
doesn't want him
to give it to him yeah she's like now
you're the prince [ __ ] yeah do the
dishes [ __ ]
she's like why should i make you the
king then you're to have power over me
true she wanted to be that number three
spot on here that's what it is
but then after she goes it doesn't get
passed to him it goes
to yeah yeah andrew well well so
charles is supposed to get it next but
they're never gonna let that happen
apparently
and so it would go to charles but they
but everyone's saying william's going to
be the
william didn't he has to give up the
royalty charleston no no that's the
other one oh no you're here i'm so sorry
for charles
he's been waiting for so long yeah i
know i feel horrible for charles i never
get to be king
yeah but he's he's like scar but i feel
like he's had a fantastic life though so
yeah no i can't tell you could tell that
he wants the crown he's like mom when
the [ __ ] are you going to die
he's a christian i literally have
nothing else i'm so bored
yeah he can't be a pop star no
[Laughter]
because there's already one prince yeah
but yeah back to this list uh
number four is that oprah winfrey number
five jennifer
jennifer lopez jennifer lopez the
world's
most admired not not richest not
influential from the block that's why
because she looks amazing for her age
i admire her should be on there for that
too she's hot as [ __ ] there's a lot of
women that look amazing for their age
i mean like that's in honestly that's
very interesting that she made
so high up what about martha stewart
martha stewart it's not on her either yo
she's a savage she needs to be on the
damn list she does
did her time came back and it's still
popping yeah oh are we with ellen
number 20. my girl right bottom is my
girl
bottom of the top of the list bottom of
the the
top yeah so yeah but what i wanted to
talk about was what joe was saying
on the guy's side it's a lot of
politicians and a lot of
uh like businessmen and entrepreneurs
on the women's side politicians yes but
then
extremely way more uh entertainers and
celebrities and singers yeah
but most of them are known for their
humanitarian work the women true
the men on the other side after that's
what i'm saying
okay i'm trying to figure johansson
taylor swift shakira beyonce
those are like literally back to back to
back to back i mean it depends on who's
voting
not famous for being humanitarian though
just yeah who's voting for angelina
johnson they're not famous for that they
did it later which is cool which is
awesome yeah and then all the men were
famous of
of like ruling people
because they're not like none of them
are really good
people bill gates tried i watched the
document he tried he tried he tried i
don't know anything
uh dude did you i mean he's he's ruth no
no i mean but that's what i mean like he
tried to help but it did you watch the
documentary on that's probably why they
give so damn much now is to try to
remedy all the [ __ ] that he's done
it was rough watching it you're like oh
yeah you kind of failed a lot
like you tried to be good and then it
just all didn't i don't think
that's the same documentary what are you
trying to deal with
like multiple episodes there's yes
there's multiple inside bill's mine
or inside the mind of bill i don't want
all
but you watch till the end you're like
wow you kind of
didn't accomplish the things that you
were trying to accomplish on the
humanitarian side of things it got
stopped
a lot do you guys based on this list do
you guys think that then
on the men and men like do people
generally admire men that are
uh competitive and then on the women's
side like do you think people in general
admire women that are more giving like
personality is
those are the qualities that we admire
about genders all the women on the list
are actually very attractive and you
made a good point
is that they were famous but they has
nothing to do with their looks though
think about it it has absolutely nothing
to do with the men's looks it's about
their power and their position yeah
you made a good point all these women
were famous before their work that they
did
but like seeing jennifer lopez on the
list makes you go are we
why are you why are we admiring her for
her work that's amazing
that is a good shot a good old butt and
it's real yeah but i mean but why are we
but why are we admiring jennifer lopez
is it her work ethic
because then that makes sense but that
makes sense as far as how the men were
yeah the competitive the competitive
numbers
any racks to richard's story is pretty
cool to see i think all of
the people on the list are like amazing
people just
in their field right but i mean the way
that we look at entertainers
we don't look at them as important as
people that are running [ __ ] in business
or politicians or whatever
yeah i wish i knew the criteria that
these people were answering the survey
how do you admire
like what does admire mean to these
people it's like you know
are you a war criminal and then they're
like okay well we'll put you on the list
yeah
are you vladimir putin we'll put you
right next to angela merkel
there's probably a lot of very
successful women that we just don't know
about and these are the faces that we
see
so who are we going to be looking up to
instead of the ones that are right in
front of us
and i think it depends on who's voting
yeah well they they definitely pulled
like
most of the countries in the world to
get this to get a proper
like figure xi jinping though come on
dude but that's what's so funny about it
that's the population thing that's
hilarious man
the census guy's at the door like who do
you admire the most and he's like she's
in pain like they have to say they have
to
like that's like going to north korea
and being like who do you admire the
most oh the dear leader who's the best
musician here the deer
yeah north korea had had a bigger
population and if they were more
integrated into the rest of the world
i'm sure
i'm sure uh what's what the [ __ ] his
name kim jong-un
and dude the day before kim jong-un took
power when his dad was alive
they would have said his dad until
tomorrow like that's how wild all that
[ __ ] is
it just flips like a switch it's like no
he's the new god
melania made the list at number 19. yeah
greta thurnberg was
right above her at 18. she's like listen
i didn't have to do a lot of stuff you
had to do to make this list
yeah i'd have to be under that she
didn't have to do nothing
she didn't even live life yet she's like
16 and she made a speech
melania's like really that's all we had
to do
you know all the [ __ ] that i had to do
look at who i'm with she's like the
things i've
seen do you know what i and then hold on
ellen's over here like seriously
we got melania above me now oh man
i mean there's probably people if
they're into it because i know some
people are really
into like the listing and their
placements like the 30 under 30 and all
that stuff could you imagine they look
at this list and go
i want to see them all in one room i
want to be more liked beyonce is under
taylor swift
holy [ __ ] did anybody else notice that
beyonce
is at number 11 taylor swift is at
number nine
is about to be pissed number shakira oh
shakira is bigger than beyonce
no way she got the latin community the
land community
but then how did taylor swift beat her
then
[Laughter]
maybe taylor swift is worldwide
i just made that up i don't know but
that's
i mean that's a that's a big one if you
were to say
that taylor swift is more popular than
beyonce in the united states
kanye's going to get pissed and he's
going to kanye's nightmare
kanye stepped into this and he's
changing it as well if we were alone
and it was just between all of us and we
all got to vote
what music are we going to play right
now i think most of us would pick taylor
swift
over beyonce i don't even know
being honest if we're being honest
you're asking the wrong person
the wrong crowd yeah definitely not we
love taylor
we love her we love her music and uh
that's just you he he
thinks of himself as multiple people so
he says we because when we cut
everyone will be like oh i love him
you just wait folks i know these people
they're like pull out your playlist
right now let me see i don't think i own
a single one of her songs i think she's
extremely talented
probably maybe because i heard it
afterwards the
would you rather listen to shake it off
or beyonce songwriting first of all
bring out the win fan we're about to get
my full beyonce on right now i'm
thinking beyonce's winning this
except beyonce as nala was
not good in the lane beyonce sounded
like this
telling simba to come back to the pride
land the whole time
that's sexy though that's a good beyonce
yeah you do a good melania too do it
again
oh no no no no i got nervous
no i didn't i got enough i guess shy
foreign